camera rolling
[Music]
little son is a way of holding hands
with the Sun the project is about our
ability to take something which is
incredibly abstract like understanding
energy and then make it somehow tangible
the idea really evolved through my
friendship with Frederic it's what we do
it's what we stand for it's what we
believe of course everybody sort of
knows about a solar panel but the way
Frederic talks about it was not like
something functional but I say something
which is more aspirational beauty and
humor and happiness and pride and
aspiration and how does that look so it
has a solar panel it has batteries on
the inside to store the energy and it
has a small LED to emit the energy of
light it's highly ventilated we actually
created an air pocket shaded air pocket
underneath the lamp and then all these
starts to act as cooling ribs its beauty
and shape leading engineering
necessities it's based on the simple but
astonishing fact at one point six
billion people in the world don't have
access to electricity the work of art in
my mind is not necessarily this piece of
plastic it's much more the whole system
of working together with different
entities and people on the way to
actually bring it to finally rural users
in a chain which will ideally have a
number of local prophets in it on the
way there is a lot of components about
the project little Sun which are very
much about social communities
infrastructure the ability to make
choices for yourself being independent
saying I'm going to take the Sun and
empower myself and I'm gonna read
tonight I'm gonna educate myself what
we're doing with little Sun is we
actually making a real impact for people
in rural areas
[Music]
my work has tried to in various ways
address this question of is reality
actually real by being really sedan
relative and is it a construction could
I change it can I change my world do
what I do have impact on my surroundings
can I feel that impact I suggest a
theoretical impact so all those
questions and if you think about it
little Sun is right in there in the
heart of all these questions you develop
a feeling about energy where you feel
that wow it has consequences if I do
this it has consequences if I do that
and suddenly I would argue you have the
foot in the door with regards to also
understanding something big as such as
the climate question you are more likely
to make environmentally conscious choice
when having grown up with this type of
felt knowledge compared to having only
read about it in books for instance it's
very nice that building is very nice
it's beautiful oh this looks like when I
studio
I've come to MIT on a number of
occasions and I've been mostly
fascinated by the participants or the
students I guess you would call them
these people are in a situation where
they have to find out how to create the
future the opportunities are immense I
mean the power of MIT is far beyond the
power of any company that I know and so
I see that collaboration take form in
many many shapes electric circuits the
material expertise is it battery
expertise is it business expertise we
need to establish non-quantifiable
success criteria in order to nurture or
train if you want this skill of being
inspired and being creative this feels
like a much more personal or small-scale
experience how would you say that this
is going to influence your work going
forward the whole idea about
investigating self-esteem the idea of
you know feeling resourceful but also
the idea of feeling interconnected
there's actually lots of components
which are in my other works creativity
is the success of the consequences that
a choice has so I choose between red or
blue but that is not a creative choice
the creativity and the choice between
red and blue is the impact that this
charge has on the world and you really
only make these creative choices once
you are inspired see now I would say
that is a skill that one can nurture I
wonder why do we lead an alert East in
order to solve this or to find the
answer for these problems I actually
don't think you need an artist at all to
be honest I do think we need to start to
treasure what creativity is capable of
[Applause]
[Music]